schena lisez ça fait quand même là
pourquoi être contre 33 3 janvier
martinique les foules et 10 sur le yoga
ou x 2 x 2 x fait une vingtaine d'années
que je viens et c'est avec beaucoup de
plaisir que je reviens surtout pour les
foules édition c'est une belle course
comme gênant c'est une crise familiale
et dans une bonne ambiance et p
je me plais à 49 ans qu'est ce qui fait
que pour toujours c'est la passion c'est
le potager de veron compte donc c'est ça
qui fait comme si en cours et puis on
aime ça et puis
j'adore ça j'aime la compétition jamais
ça il ya surtout leur ce côté aussi
plaisir aussi
donc voilà parce que cet esprit de
compétition il ya cette exclu de se
faire plaisir aussi
alors cette victoire déjà votre votre
palmarès vous allez chercher la 6e là eh
ben c'est vrai que cette année j'ai un
petit accident au niveau du bois on va
être cassée et j'ai dit comme un trouble
93 3 mois mais je tenais quand même
parce que des foules et j'adore les
foules et donc je viens pas beaucoup
d'entraînements ben je suis un guerrier
donc je viens pour gagner même si je me
blesse mais je ne pouvais aller ramer